in today's digital age cyber security
has become Paramount concern for
individuals businesses and governments
across the world as a Reliance on
technology grows exponentially so does
the need to protect our valuable data
from malicious activities cyber security
encompasses a range of practices and
Technologies aim with safeguarding
computer systems networks and sensitive
information from any unauthorized access
reception or theft the demand for cyber
Security Professionals has skyrocketed
in recent years and continues to grow at
an unprecedented rate as cyber threats
evolve and become more sophisticated
organizations require skilled experts
who can anticipate detect and mitigate
potential risks looking ahead the future
of cyber security is poised for Rapid
advancements and the skills required in
this field are diverse and ever evolving
with the rise of emerging Technologies
such as AI cloud computing iot new
vulnerabilities and cyber attacks will
emerge as a result cyber Security
Professionals will need to adapt and
specialize in these areas to effectively
protect against cyber threats on that
note hello everyone welcome to Simply
learn in this video we will dive into an
insightful discussion on the top 5
skills you need to master as a cyber
security specialist and other critical
attributes that hold significant value
for individuals as per it know enter the
cyber security field but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to Simply on
YouTube channel to stay updated with all
various Technologies and hit that Bell
icon to never miss an update from us
having said that as we all know with
cyber attacks becoming more prevalent
and severe it has become crucial to
address the cyber security skill Gap and
overcome the shortage of cyber Talent so
if you are interested in personal career
in cyber security and acquiring the
necessary skills then our Caltech cyber
security bootcamp can be the right
option for you gain expertise in
defensive and offensive cyber security
digital forensics ethical hacking and
penetration testing and other crucial
domains with Caltech cyber security boot
camp our comprehensive program offers a
curriculum that encompasses a wide range
of in-demand cyber security tools
Hands-On labs and guided practices
throughout the course you will mark on a
well-structured Learning Journey
starting with fundamental cyber security
Concepts and progressing to asset and
inventory management Network systems
Python Programming system administration
offensive security and defensive
security practices and to ensure your
Readiness for the industry you'll also
engage in multiple projects allowing you
to hone your skills and emerge as an
exceptional cyber security professional
furthermore you will gain Proficiency in
using various tools and Technologies
such as Wireshark python Linux and other
relevant resources so hurry up and find
the course Link in the description box
for more details so without any further
Ado let's get started firstly let us
have a quick introduction to what is
cyber security Now cyber security is a
critical discipline that safeguards our
Digital World ensuring the protection of
sensitive information privacy and smooth
operation of digital systems it is an
ongoing battle against constantly
evolving threats requiring continuous
learning vigilance and proactive
measures various cyber security threats
like malware attacks phishing scams
ransomware can have severe consequences
including Financial losses reputational
damage privacy violations and disruption
of critical services so in order for the
smooth functioning of all these cyber
security is essential at every level to
maintain trust privacy and smooth
functioning of our digital ecosystem
did you know that the global cyber
security Market is projected to reach
366 billion dollars by 2028 and more
than 1 million cyber security jobs will
be available by then now currently there
is a requirement of more than 4 lakh
cyber Security Professionals in the job
market which has increased from 11
percent in 2023 and will go up to by 20
in 2025. but now comes the main question
why do cyber security skills matter now
cyber security skills are vital for
protecting organizations individuals and
critical digital assets from
ever-evolving cyber threats the
contribute to maintaining data privacy
ensuring business continuity and
building trust in the digital ecosystem
so here are the some of the main reasons
why you should be learning cyber
security first one production against
cyber threats well it is obvious right
cyber security skills enables
individuals and organizations to
effectively defend against a wide range
of cyber threats that such as hacking
attempts malware infections data
breaches and much more these skills help
identify vulnerabilities Implement
preventive measures and responsively to
mitigate potential risk secondly
safeguarding sensitive information
now with the increasing amount of
personal adsensitive data stored
digitally cyber security skills are
crucial for protecting this information
from unauthorized access or disclosure
cyber Security Professionals employ
encryption access controls and secure
protocols to ensure the confidentiality
and privacy of sensitive data and
finally mitigating financial and
reputational damage now cyber security
breaches can result in significant
financial losses and damage to
organization's reputation cyber security
play a vital role in preventing such
incidents and minimize their impact by
implementing effective security measures
professionals can protect against data
breaches intellectual property theft and
other cyber crams that could lead to
financial and reputational consequences
so without any further delay let us
directly jump into what are the top five
skills that you need and possess as a
cyber security specialist in 2023
so first skill that we need to have is
network and Security Administration now
what is network and Security
Administration networking and system
administration are fundamental for
maintaining secure network
infrastructures professionals with these
skills possess a deep understanding of
network protocols configuration and
administration practices furthermore
their expertise in system
administrations allows them to secure
operating systems manage users accounts
apply patches and ensure overall system
Integrity so here are some of the
certifications that you can pursue to
become a network and Security
Administration expert now first one is
compti Security Plus this certification
focuses on Foundation cyber security
skills and covers topics such as network
security threats and vulnerabilities
access control and incident response it
is valuable for network and system
administrators who need to understand
and Implement security measures next we
have Cisco CCNA certification now this
CCNA certification is offered by Cisco
and validates the knowledge and skills
required to install configure operate
and troubleshoot medium size rooted and
switch networks it covers topics like
Network fundamentals land and man
Technologies security and wireless
networking and much more
so moving ahead the next skill that you
need to have or possess is operating
systems and virtual machines knowledge
now Proficiency in operating systems
like Windows Linux and Mac OS is crucial
for cyber Security Professionals they
possess the knowledge required to secure
operating systems configure system
settings manage user permissions and
conduct regular system maintenance
additionally familiarity with
virtualization Technologies such as
VMware and virtualbox enables
professionals to create and manage
virtual machines for various purposes
including testing development and
isolating environments for security
analysis so for this you can also have a
good certification to become an expert
in various operating systems and virtual
machines firstly we have com Tia a plus
certification now this certification
covers fundamental knowledge of computer
hardware operating systems like Windows
Linux Mac OS and virtualizations it
validates skills in installing
configuring maintaining and
troubleshooting computer systems next we
have VMware certified professional
certificate which offers several
certification related to virtualization
such as vcp dcv which are the data
center virtualization and the desktop
and Mobility certification skills in
deploying managing and troubleshooting
VMware virtualization Technologies and
virtual machines
moving ahead the next skill that you
need to possess is cryptography and
network security control skills
now what is cryptography and network
security control firstly let us
understand what is cryptography now
cryptography Braves a vital role in
ensuring the confidentiality integrity
and authenticity of data it is done
through encryption and decryption which
is used to secure networks and
information which is nothing but
cryptography now cryptography
understands different cryptographic
algorithms encryption techniques and
secure key management practices which
utilizations to secure settings of
information protect data in transit and
rest and verify the identity of
communicating parties now network
security control skills are also
essential for protecting networks from
threats and attacks now professionals
proficient in this area possess
expertise in configuring and managing
firewalls intuition detection systems
and virtual private networks and other
network security devices moving ahead
the next skill that you need to possess
as a cyber security expert is cloud
security
now as you all know organizations are
increasingly adopting to cloud services
and expertise in Cloud security becomes
indispensable nowadays cyber Security
Professionals proficient in Cloud
security possess a thorough
understanding of plot architecture
service models and deployment models so
having a good knowledge on
infrastructure security which involves
securing the underlying Cloud
infrastructure including physical data
centers servers storage and network
components so they are adapted
implementing robust security networks
and Control Management Systems managing
access and identifying through identity
and access management systems which is
crucial in Cloud security to control and
manage user identities roles and access
to Cloud resources this includes
implementing strong multiplication
ensuring secure data storage and
maintaining compliance within Cloud
environment
and finally network security Now Cloud
networks need to be protected against
unauthorized access and network-based
attacks which involves implementing
firewalls intuition detection systems
and vpns so having a good knowledge on
network security on cloud-based
infrastructure is a must knowledge
additionally knowledge on cloud services
providers like AWS Azure or Google Cloud
platform enables them to secure Cloud
infrastructure effectively
and finally on the list we have that
intelligence and risk management now
what is that intelligence and risk
management that intelligence and risk
management are closely linked threat
intelligence provide valuable insights
that feed into the risk management
processes now threat intelligence and
risk management skills involve
understanding and managing potential
risk to an organization information
assets professionals skilled in this
area connectrix assessment identify
vulnerabilities and develop mitigation
strategies having expertise in this will
help organizations build a resilient
cyber security posture and respond
effectively to emerging threats so some
of the certifications that you can have
on threat intelligence and its
management as cdia and Cisco certified
CC IP which will ensure to stay updated
on the latest threats vulnerabilities
and attack vectors through intelligence
sources by analyzing and correlating
thread data professionals can identify
potential risks and Implement
appropriate security measures to
mitigate them
so those were some of the top five cyber
security skills that you need to possess
as a cyber security specialist I hope
you understood and with that you've come
to the end of today's session guys I
hope the video was informative and
helpful if you have any further queries
regarding any of the concepts called
into this tutorial let us know in the
comment section below and a team of
experts will be more than happy to help
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign